we've already heard about Donald Trump's
pick for national security
Monica Crowley's conspiracy theories
we've talked about that a little bit but
now we have learned about Monica
Crowley's plagiarisms CNN is reporting
that Monica Crowley the conservative
author television personality
sister-in-law of liberal radio host Alan
Colmes plagiarized large amounts of her
2012 book called what the bleep just
happened the happy warriors guide to the
great American comeback an investigation
found at least 50 instances of
plagiarism from different sources in her
book this includes think-tank materials
Wikipedia other news articles even other
column lists the columnist the book is
listed as a New York Times best seller
it doesn't have a bibliography doesn't
have endnotes at the book in the end of
the book or footnotes throughout the
book and HarperCollins who published the
book said that they're no longer going
to sell it saying that it has quote
reached the end of its natural sales
cycle that's interesting let's take a
look at some of these plagiarized
excerpts from Monica Crowley's book here
is page 232 of Monica Crowley's book
next to James Rosen for Fox News in 2010
and you see stunning similarities I
won't read them all to you but our video
audience is seeing that they're they're
just essentially identical passages - a
few words here or there senior director
of strategic communications for the
National Security Council of Donald
Trump she plagiarized her own book
should we be shocked by this or actually
just thinking yeah I kind of fits with
everything Trump is doing I don't think
I'm too shocked I mean you have to
wonder if this was actually ghostwritten
by Melania Trump speechwriter yes that's
true
Melania Trump copied her RNC speech who
I would be surprised that Monica Crowley
is given being given a job after she
plagiarized a bunch of her book there's
a whole bunch of other examples stuff
about Keynesian economics from wicked
from
investopedia there's a section about
organized labor which came from a 2004
article by a libertarian think-tank
there's pieces from fox news articles
it's just all a big laugh over on the
right where they don't even seem to take
this seriously do they I mean the
Melania Trump thing was not taken very
seriously yeah this is question now on
the right as to what you can accept as
fact or fiction or and I think they're
equating this to what you can see is
plagiarized or your own words it just
it's amazing to me that exceptions are
made for things that would never be
forgiven if they were happening in a
hypothetical Hillary Clinton
administration the stuff in the
background of Trump's cabinet picks if
you had equivalent things if you had
equivalent of issues for a democratic
cabinet pick it would never be excused
the way Fox News and the right and and
Sean Hannity and Rush Limbaugh are all
excusing it Monica Crowley a plagiarize
er going to work for the number one
political person in the United States I
guess as scary as it is to say that
today's show is brought to you by go
daddy where you can buy your own domain
name build a website or use any of Go
Daddy's business tools you can save 30%
at try go daddy.com slash David GoDaddy
has actually been the official host of
the David Pakman show website for many
many many years the 24/7 customer
support has been a very good thing for
us I've called them at really odd times
when we've had website issues and they
are always available they are the
largest domain registrar and whether you
have a new idea you're an established
business you're creating a personal
website or moving your large enterprise
site over to GoDaddy they can do it all
thirteen million customers try it and
get 30 percent off at try go daddy.com
slash David